well not everyone has made it back from
lunch
um but we go get started now so I'm
delighted to introduce miles who you
know the rest of his time works on
planetary models or something like that
um but into in
um in today's talk is going to be
talking about symbolic distillation of
neural networks we'll go for it
uh can you hear me through this one okay
cool okay uh so I'm going to talk about
um one strategy for converting uh
insights learned by Deep neural networks
into a a language that we can understand
okay
so um what I want I want an AI scientist
okay I want a machine learning algorithm
that will actually do science for me and
help me in my scientific research
um but I think a lot of existing machine
learning research has been driven mostly
by computer vision natural language
benchmarks
this was motivated by industry interests
robotics
um attempts to reach human level
performance on various tasks and kind of
uh you have these different benchmarks
along the way it's like image
classification for example
um and I think this is a problem for
machine learning of Science and science
research because I feel like a lot of
machine learning science research just
takes computer vision or NLP benchmarks
and kind of swaps the data with
scientific data sets but I think like
this is not really this kind of misses
the point so I think machine learning
plus science we kind of need to go
backwards uh work backwards from we want
to discover new science and kind of
build up problems that support that
so um I want AI to reach human level
performance at doing Natural Science
research what needs to happen so Natural
Science it's not a regression problem
it's not a classification problem you
need to have an understanding of the
things the model learns this is kind of
a key uh difference here
um we want to be able to use machine
learning for discovering kind of
universal Concepts and representing them
in human language this is kind of the
the key difference so okay how do we
traditionally do science so we we have
maybe some data set maybe it's a low
dimensional summary statistic and we try
to describe it with Theory so we come up
with different theories to try to
describe that data set
um so for example a Kepler's third law
was uh I think it was like 80 years
before Newton's law of gravity but
Newton's law of gravity was ultimately
created to explain this
it wasn't an apple in case you didn't
know that uh Planck's law is actually
another empirical expression so this was
kind of a relationship that was observed
in data with a little bit of theory and
then quantum mechanics was was partially
created to explain things like this
um but if I have this neural network
this large model that's trained on
diverse data and it's kind of
everything's kind of stuck in this
neural network space I I can't really
build theories that describe this right
so this is kind of my problem
um so
I think one approach and this is what
I'm going to tell you about I think one
approach to kind of solving this
difference is when we go from a high
dimensional data set to a neural net
which is which is
kind of like a compression
is it getting feedback
I don't know so this is kind of like a
compression so we go to neural net space
uh I'm going to tell you how to do the
final step as a distillation so kind of
converting this neural net learned
compression into Theory uh which is kind
of I think one possible way we can
efficiently use machine learning to kind
of build up
um Theory okay so my key point that I'm
going to try to convince you of in this
presentation is is neural Nets trained
on massive data sets they can find new
insights so they can have new insights
kind of buried in the weights
that they've uh learned from kind of
training on completely unrelated so you
think data sets
um the the real challenge is kind of
pulling out that insight and Distilling
okay what did it actually learn and how
can we use that to improve our
scientific theories so okay so I'm going
to talk about interpretability I'll tell
you about this idea called symbolic
regression
talk about neural distillation we'll go
through a couple examples okay so the
the traditional way of uh interpreting
neural networks kind of involves feature
importance so say I have this image
classifier uh and I look at okay what is
the most sensitive part of the image
what is my classifier sensitive to maybe
it's like the faces of the Lions or the
face of a dog this is traditionally how
you would do feature importance in
computer vision or language
um
this is a this is a fun example from a
paper in 2016 this uses this
interpretability technique called lime
essentially you can try to interrogate
the model and see uh what's important to
it so here's a dog playing the guitar
and so if you interrogate the
probability for electric guitar
kind of highlights that part acoustic
guitar maybe it highlights that part or
Labrador kind of identifies that part
um so so this is kind of how you would
do interpretability in in computer
vision NLP but I think like in science
we already have a modeling language and
I think it's really important to exploit
that so computer vision I don't really
have a model for a dog or a cat like
there's no mathematical model for a cat
but in in science we do we do have like
a really strong framework for describing
the universe right mathematical
equations
um so if you look at like a cheat sheet
of physics you can see that there's so
many different analytic Expressions they
very accurately model our universe
um so I think when we do
interpretability for machine learning
and science we should really
try to get explanations in this language
rather than just feature importances
so uh for physical problems one nice
part about this is that when you
interpret the model with symbolic
Expressions
um you can often get better
generalization performance than the
original neural network you're kind of
uh explaining so
um I'll give some more examples of this
but this is this is kind of like an
alternate inductive bias
so if you think about like when you when
you train a neural network
there's kind of like this implicit prior
over the space of functions it could
take on right when you search over the
space of analytic Expressions that's a
different prior over the space of
functions and it seems to be really good
for modeling the universe and I think
this is because
the analytic operators that we're used
to they kind of have these geometrical
properties like plus is like spatial
translation multiplication is like
length to area to volume uh and then you
have a range of other operators that are
kind of like solutions to different
differential equations so I think this
is kind of a it's a
cool kind of inductive bias it's more of
like a functional inductive bias
um so this brings me to this technique
called symbolic regression this is what
I've worked on uh for the past few years
um essentially it's a way of
it's a machine learning task where you
search for analytic Expressions that
optimize some objective Okay so
if I have this equation y equals z plus
two sine Z
this would kind of be represented by
this tree and I would search over the
space of trees until I find one that
fits my data set
okay so so rather than fitting
parameters in some fixed model you're
searching over the space of trees while
fitting those parameters
um
so the state of the art approach to this
is actually a genetic algorithm there
have been kind of like Transformer based
approaches but they don't win benchmarks
yet so genetic algorithms are actually
state of the art for this task
um
so for example
I might do a mutation on a tree kind of
like switch operators and these are just
ways of exploring this space of
Expressions okay you can also breed
Expressions so maybe you have
one symbolic expression that fits this
part of the data set another expression
that fits this part of the data set you
might breed them together and kind of
cross over
um so these are all just ways of
exploring the space but what you're
trying to do in symbolic regression is
jointly optimize accuracy of the fit and
minimize complexity
so complexity is very
complex it's a very complex subject but
essentially it's user defined so you
could think of like the number of nodes
as the complexity of an expression
so symbolic regression is trying to
optimize accuracy and complexity okay so
there's a couple open source Frameworks
that I've worked on
piser and symbolic regression.jl if
you're interested I encourage you to
check them out
I think this is it's a really useful
technique for kind of interpreting
neural networks I'll show you some
examples of that
um the way these codes work
is it uses a technique called
multi-population evolution
so essentially if I have this population
of Expressions so these are like
different candidate Expressions that
each fit the data in a different way
um what I do is I randomly sample those
so I randomly sample maybe like two
expressions
of those I compute the fitness
so maybe the fitness is like a
combination of accuracy and complexity
I take the fittest and then I do a
perturbation so maybe I mutate it maybe
I algebraically simplify it maybe I do a
constant optimization these are just
ways of exploring the space
I take that perturb expression and I put
it back in my population
essentially you just go through this
Loop enough times yeah
yeah so you go through this Loop enough
times and you'll eventually arrive at
you'll converge to a point in expression
space yeah so this evolution is not
using any language model this is just
like simple python yeah okay so there
are uh language model approaches they
they work well if you know the space of
Expressions that you're searching like
you know maybe the ground truth and you
kind of put those in your training data
set
um but it's really hard to get General
language model approaches to this
um I'm yeah it's another question yeah
in this case are you trying to fit the
original data or are you training a
neural network then trying to fit the
neural network with the expression yeah
second second yeah yeah I'll I'll show
an example of that yeah
[Music]
okay uh so the way you scale this so so
this is all I'm gonna get back to neural
networks this is the interpretation
strategy so you can scale this up uh so
the way you you scale this over many
chords is you kind of have different
populations of Expressions living on
different chords
you can kind of think of them as like
islands of expressions and they each go
through Evolution different Islands will
kind of will kind of specialize so maybe
one island is like polynomials one
island is exponentials it's kind of like
different species okay they evolve
independently and the reason for this is
you get a nice parallelism right you can
evolve them on different cores after a
number of iterations you have migration
between between these uh islands and
that's kind of how you uh do massive
searches yes sorry yeah
um so that your procedure doesn't look
inside the neural net at all it just
looks at the input output is it yeah so
I'll get yeah I'll get back to that yeah
okay yeah
that's one question two yes I mean
it doesn't feel like this would make
very good progress as a search procedure
because I mean for some things like
addition it might be okay but it sort of
feels like if you're considering taking
two expressions and multiplying them
that what comes out is not going to look
anything like either if your component
Expressions before so you mean the
breeding itself yeah like it doesn't so
the okay this doesn't feel like it's
going to be very goal directed yeah so
the simplest way to think of like how
the breeding could help you is just
think about feature importance say you
have 100 variables the most important
variable is going to appear in more
expressions and so when you do the cross
breeding you're more likely to have that
variable put into your expression tree
um now of course it's much more complex
than that because you can have kind of
atomic sub-expressions so maybe the same
sub expression appears in many different
trees uh maybe it appears in the same
expression multiple times it's kind of
like a
a way of thinking about feature
importance the cross breeding
um yeah I mean genetically like genetic
algorithms kind of seem like there's
there's not really any kind of uh it
seems like a dumb idea but it it it's
the best idea we have basically like
it's uh so there's a yearly competition
called symbolic regression bench uh at
Gecko
um the winners are always genetic
algorithms
unfortunately yeah
it's our bench
it's about a progression bench yeah
okay uh so
I'll just I'll do a couple more slides
on this and we get back to neural
networks so this is kind of how it looks
when you're searching so if I I'm trying
to fit this line I do different
perturbations maybe on mutated node
Coast to sign do a constant optimization
do more candidates it's kind of like I'm
mcmc expression space
um I spent way too long in this I'm
going to replay it
okay
[Laughter]
add a node these are all different like
I'm just exploring the space of
expressions with evolution
Tate
and and uh there are some kind of MCTS
approaches so you can you can
uh weight the probabilities based on the
current expression but um so my code
pyster just uses fixed probabilities
okay uh so
what's this one oh yeah
yeah so there's a python API
uh okay back to neural networks so
the point that I want to get across in
this presentation is we can use this
symbolic regression
to distill a neural network into an
equation okay and then we can get
insight from that and uh so
the the basic idea is that you train a
neural network normally
so whatever the neural network is you
train it normally
after training you freeze the parameters
you just stop training freeze the
parameters
then you observe the latent spaces so
maybe I look at this latent space and I
kind of record what goes in I look at
the output so this other latent space
and I record the outputs
once I have enough of those over my
maybe training set then I feed those
into my symbolic regression code and I
fit different Expressions to it
okay
with the original data set without doing
the news yeah great question so uh I'll
get back to that but yeah that's a good
question yeah so
the full idea is that you would do this
at multiple parts of your network to
kind of build up this hierarchy of
symbolic expressions
so maybe I have two Networks
maybe maybe this is like a graph Network
this is my node update model this is
like my Edge update model what I would
do is first fit this network and kind of
replace it with expressions
and so I I kind of replace the neural
network with my symbolic expressions
then I retrain my second Network and
this this just kind of helps pick up any
errors in training the first Network
and then I would replace my second
Network
and so now I've I've kind of completely
replaced every part of my network with
expressions with symbolic Expressions
um and so this is ultimately
uh more interpretable than just this
massive neural network model right so
the reason you would not just do direct
symbolic regression is because of the
combinatorial explosion so if you were
to search for this expression directly
you would have to consider many more
symbolic Expressions than if you
consider this separately from this so
the the scaling is going from N squared
Expressions to two n expressions
it's basically a way of factorizing the
problem
into sub-expressions but I guess what
I'm wondering is like the the uh space
of functions that a single hidden layer
neural network can represent is the same
as the space of functions that a deep
Network can represent so is it is is
just because of the input and out to put
dimensionality or is it just because
it's it's actually simpler in practice
or something else uh so what you would
normally have is is some kind of
inductive bias to eliminate the
functional degeneracy
and you would
um I guess you would
you would assume that f is some
complexity expression and and G the
second network is a is the same
complexity expression
um and so rather than searching over all
possible expressions of both networks
combined you would just do one at a time
and you can't be it's kind of like a
student teacher approach but you can
like parts of the network you can't
provably say that this has this module
has this amount of complexity you just
sort of assume it does because it's pray
to God yeah if it's like more
complicated than your expression you're
you're kind of screwed so like one of
the problems with this approach is you
have to make a choice of what operators
you're going to use to distill the
network
um you would usually choose those
operators based on what would give you
the best interpretation so if it is some
I mean if it's some problem in
astrophysics I would choose like plus
minus multiplication exponential
logarithm but if I was in maybe particle
physics I would choose like dial
logarithm and kind of operators common
in that field
yeah so you gave some graphical examples
before it looked like interpolation is
this the type or method for achieving
interpolation
it's uh
so okay the basic idea is that when you
train a neural network you are
implicitly assuming some prior over the
space of functions when you do this
symbolic distillation you're kind of
transferring it to a different prior
so that when you go out of distribution
you get the second prior you get the
symbolic prior
I'll open this later yeah okay
um
yes I was wondering if does this assume
any restriction on the structure or
topology of the neural net that has to
kind of conform
uh that's a good question so no so you
would normally just choose a multi like
a normal multi-layer perceptron like if
you're doing like graph networks
um
you would not
impose any kind of functional
regularization
I mean there's going to be an
approximation error right like you're
not going to get a perfect approximation
of the multi-layer perceptron because
that would be an infinitely complex
expression you're trying to find a
simple
approximation of the behavior of that
multi-layer perceptron it's going to be
an approximation though
it seems like
yeah
like in your previous slides when you
were showing uh this iterative process
you you kind of knew what to fit to
which part of the network or maybe I
miss understanding that we are like
we're searching with a genetic algorithm
over the space of expressions
right choose the operators you have to
make that choice you have to choose the
operators you have to choose how you
Define complexity those are arbitrary
decisions that you would base on your
constraints
um there's not really any
I mean yeah there's not really any like
fundamental reason you would choose one
operator so the ground show but is is
the expression do you have a ground
truth expression that you I mean it
depends on the problem like sometimes
you're trying to ReDiscover something to
show you can kind of reach human level
performance but other times you're
actually discovering new scientific
equations
in those cases you would choose
maybe you would have a
maybe you would kind of Base it oh okay
this field is usually uh described well
with these operators so I would kind of
choose those operators in my search but
um
I mean like you might just not know the
operator sure uh that would be best so
that that could be like a different
optimization problem
like learning the operator
okay
so
um
yeah so the so traditional approach you
have you data you try to describe it
with a theory in this
uh kind of proposed idea you would go
from data to a neural network so you
kind of compress any patterns in that
data set with a neural network then you
distill it to symbolic form
okay
uh so I'll talk about some examples so
uh one of the first things we tried in
this 2020 Europe's paper was
graph neural networks graph neural
networks are quite easy to interpret
with this strategy because they have a
similar functional form to force laws
from classical physics so what you do
when you interpret a graph neural
network so say we're trying to predict
the Dynamics of like some interacting
particles with a graph Network what we
do is we encourage low dimensionality in
the message passing space
and that gives us uh it essentially
forces the graph Network to have few
latent
uh it's basically a few equations
um
so I'll just show this video so we start
off we generate simulations of particles
so this is a spring law
we try to model this with a graph
Network graph neural network
okay so we try to predict these Dynamics
with the graph neural network
so these are the predictions
in Gray and the ground truth is colored
so we we do this with the graph neural
network we regularize them with L1 and
this is essentially
telling the graph Network I want you to
find a simple model for me like I want
to have few equations and you can see
here it only finds two equations there's
two latent Dimensions that it uses and
all the other ones are sparse
um so what this essentially gives us is
that when we try to fit
symbolic regression to it we get two
equations that we replace the edge model
with
um and those happen to be the same as
the spring law so we've kind of shown
that
the message passing function in this
graph network is the spring law so I
mean this is a rediscovery but it's a
test for this approach
okay
so so the next thing we did is knowledge
Discovery like the the whole idea of
this approach is that
you want to find the scientific insights
that deep learning is finding from data
so we had so we're asked we're from an
astrophysic background so we have this
dark matter simulation we want to find
um
uh new kind of laws that describe the
clustering of dark matter okay
we have this graph neural network we
train it
to predict the properties of of dark
matter
based on kind of the surrounding
particles
which tells you about the clustering of
dark matter
um so the neural network is able to beat
uh traditional metrics for this but we
want to understand okay like like what
Insight is it using that it's able to
beat traditional metrics yeah
should I do that
yeah maybe maybe there's bed and bread
bread and butter in your field but just
uh how do you represent continuous
matter with the graphic great question
so uh you would traditionally do
there's this approach called a Halo
finder it basically draws balls around
uh Blobs of dark matter
those become nodes in the graph
oh dark matter is discreet no uh so
Darkness yeah like the simulation kind
of represents it continuously but you
would do a search kind of for clusters
of dark matter
those clusters become nodes in the graph
and the the the nodes would have
properties like this is the mass of this
cluster this is the uh the radius things
like that
so that's how you desperatize the
simulation into a graph the edges are
just based on locality you just do a
radius cut
so if you can stimulate it and you're
not using some physical laws like
gravitational loss to stimulate it
already yes are you landing something
more than what you are putting into the
simulation we're learning a summary
statistic for kind of how it clusters
but the ground truth physics is known
because we're simulating it like it's
just gravity right we're learning uh how
the mass is clustered
so like what's a good law for clustering
it is effective physics basically
effective law so basically it's an
emergent properties from the
gravitational loss that is coming
beta representations
certain properties that are coming from
gravitational loss yeah it's basically
learning a lot that describes the
emergent properties in the simulation
okay
okay uh so yes we apply the same
approach that we used to get the spring
laws and we get this
uh Dark Matter over to NCAA equation it
basically predicts properties of the
dark matter based on a summation of the
neighbors
um so I'm not gonna
describe this because uh it's different
field but uh it's basically like a new
equation so this equation was not known
before and the graph neural network
found it and then we distilled it with
symbolic regression
um so it kind of describes the
clustering of the dark matter
um okay so the I'll show a second
example so this one's more classical we
wanted to see can we find Newton's law
of gravity
from
the Solar System Dynamics okay so
unknown masses unknown dynamical model
we literally just fit the solar system
with a graph neural network try to
predict the next step of every planet
um so this was led by Pablo Lemos at
Mila
um
so it basically looks like this the the
wireframes are the predictions the
colored
planets are the ground truth this is
another video that took us way too long
to make and I regret doing it
uh
and you can see so the original graph
Network like it doesn't quite pick up
all the Dynamics it kind of looks like
it but it doesn't pick up everything
yeah
not to take away anything from it but
wouldn't you want to do this with what
was known at the time about the Dynamics
you know in terms of the observations of
yeah so oh okay I think I see what
you're saying so you would say like why
not give it like a 2d Sky Map
is that what you're asking
no okay I guess what I was asking is
what's the input you know is the input
so the input is we give out the orbits
right now today no so we give it as
input 3D positions of every planet and
then
I think it's like 20 moons
over time
right so give it the precise 3D position
exactly we don't give it the masses we
don't give it any orbital parameters yes
give it the raw physical coordinates
they're good
okay for now
okay so we we train this network it's
not perfect so we want to okay we want
to use this new interpretability
technique and understand what is the
what are the latent spaces actually
doing like what are they actually
Computing they stick it into piser and
we get these equations out so
this axis is complexity and this is
essentially like
I mean I should have done accuracy it's
accuracy complexity trade-off basically
says like this is a good bang for your
buck
um okay the simplest expression X over R
you get X over R plus a constant we keep
adding complexity and we get to this
expression which is Newton's law so mass
times mass times x over R cubed so it's
basically like the X component of the
force
um there was actually another expression
so this is actually this fits the latent
space better it's basically Newton's law
of gravity plus a consonant
um and we realize like that's just the
degeneracy in the network like it's
basically learning its own modified law
of gravity that works because it's kind
of it knows how to invert it but
um you can see the complexity trade-off
is just not worth it
um so we prefer this one which of course
happens to be the
ground truth Newton's law um okay so we
we take this law we take this symbolic
expression replace the neural network
and we roll it out again
and we see like okay how well does it do
um
and so yeah it looks better
I mean it's it's not perfect like
this is uh Mercury Mercury's prediction
is still off
um
okay so we try to figure out okay like
why isn't it perfect this is Newton's
law of gravity like it should be perfect
um so I mentioned earlier that we're
letting the network learn Mass values
for every planet we don't give that as
prior information it has to learn the
masses
um and a lot of the masses are just
completely off
um so so the predictions are in red and
the the multiple dots is basically
different trials
um you can see like Earth
is like Way underpredicted by like a
hundred times uh Mars is way
underpredicted some of the biggest
planets it gets
because I I think yeah those are just
easier to predict
um but we realize like okay this network
is
it's essentially learning a modified law
of gravity that works for the network
and it's learning Mass values that work
with
that law
um okay so what we did is we have this
law of gravity we retrain the masses
so we re-optimize the masses to work
with that symbolic distillation
which is like remember we're
like the original masses that it learned
were optimized for the full neural
network not the symbolic expression
okay it's not a perfect approximation of
the network it's kind of learned this
modified theory of gravity so we
re-optimize the mass parameters
uh and and then it's good and then it
gets it correctly uh you can see all the
predictions are uh
predictions are good again okay
so uh yeah I mean all the predictions
are good a couple are weird like this is
the moon Hyperion like over predicts the
masses I think it's just because we had
like some moons missing from the data
set
um so we're not worried about that
okay third example this is my final
example
so a lot of what I talked about is about
interpretability so converting to
analytic expressions for interpretation
another cool thing you can do is when
you translate it to a symbolic
expression you can do it for Speed so
this is a paper led by a grad student at
uh Wisconsin
and they use symbolic regression to
optimize the speed of a neural network
so you take the inputs and outputs of a
neural network
and you try to find the fastest possible
expression on an fpga that approximates
that neural network and so
rather than searching for complexity
you're searching for number of clock
Cycles on the fpga so it's like
completely different objective
um but it's the same kind of idea you're
trying to distill it to a symbolic
expression so they approximate a neural
network with 90 accuracy so you can get
pretty good predictions and it's five
nanosecond inference time
so their application is the Large Hadron
Collider for kind of detecting anomalous
particles and so rather than needing to
have this massive neural network you can
distill it to this Ultra fast fpga code
with this idea and get really fast
prediction
um
yeah and I think I'll stop there there's
so I have this web page of like other
examples of this
um
I think so yeah that this the things I
want I'm interested in discussing are
um
is a pure neural network approach to AI
for science possible like if we just
keep training larger and larger models
would we ever expect to get the same
level of generalization compared to
Theory so like
you know uh so Einstein's general
relativity was derived from only a few
ideas but it can predict things like
black holes right like obviously he
didn't observe a black hole
uh he just derived it
um so is it hopeless to kind of expect
that level of generalization from
Foundation models
um or do we need to kind of have this
mix of distilling them to Theory
um
and then uh yeah another thing I'm
interested in is like how do we distill
very large models like language models
into scientific insights like can we use
this idea or uh
um do we have to take other approaches
um
yeah okay I'll stop there thanks for
coming
thanks for having me
full-time more questions
I guess I could follow up my on my
previous question I think you alluded to
it here with in terms of uh general
relativity Etc so I I was getting at the
same point with respect to gravity in
the sense that
when um
when the law was formulated I'm assuming
that there weren't you know 3D
coordinates for all the planets over
time and so on so yeah so the
predictions are done in in
with extremely small amounts of data and
yeah and so is this a dual view where
there's
um of science where there's lots of data
and you use neural Nets and then then
derive or can you discuss a little more
about where this would be applicable
uh so I don't quite follow the question
is the question about specifically
Newton law of gravity no well it was it
was sort of saying look uh there seems
to be
you know uh
okay so so my first my first reaction to
to the uh to the derivation of uh of uh
Newton's law was uh wow that's really
remarkable right it's uh but then then I
thought well but but it's using much
more information than than was used in
historically yeah and so if you're
saying well this is a way to to get at
science it's in a different domain
perhaps so right can you discuss a
little bit about that yeah so the
network is not at the level of Newton
I'll say that like it's a simple neural
network so I think there's a lot more
work uh to be done uh so we also had to
put in so I didn't mention this but we
had to put in another few inductive
biases in the network to actually get
that performance on that data set so it
is a lot of data so we gave it 30 years
of Dynamics data
but uh but actually
it's only I think there's only 30 bodies
so uh uh like planets and moons in the
sun it's it's just not a lot of data for
neural networks like you only have 30
examples it's really hard for the neural
network to pick up a general principle
and I think that's why I kind of learned
this modified Theory
um so I think
like I ultimately think we just need
better ways to impose
Simplicity priors on latent spaces in
neural networks kind of like uh symbolic
Simplicity like I would love some kind
of way to impose that
parts of a neural network learn a
symbolically simple model
um but it seems hard to do that
but yeah the like I think we need to
eliminate so we had the rotation
equivalence was another inductive bias
that we put in but we didn't need to
necessarily
so there's a few other priors that we
want to remove and still recover that
result
yeah so you may have actually answered
my earlier question about interpolation
and on Einstein's prerogative and
general relativity Mercury's perihelion
was part of his historical motivation
for that Pursuit yep I'm assuming you
knew that like getting into this so like
when you come up with like better
matching with Mercury's orbit as an
elliptical orbit does this basically
imply that you are demonstrating
elliptic curve interpolation
um so yeah so
um regarding the procession of Mercury
so I think there's just like it it
barely learned Newton's law of gravity
because you only have 31 different
masses you're training this neural
network on
um I think it's just not enough data to
kind of fit
the neural network and uh like it barely
found Newton's love gravity I don't
think it would have found general
relativity unless we gave it a lot more
data well I mean before we gave it like
different principles yeah well Einstein
did say from like the Mercury's orbit
that he like was corroborating
everything about like his concept of
general relativity was motivation yeah
to do further work so I'm not saying
like you know QBE that's what you should
expect yeah I think like you know like
did you demonstrate in the way that you
got really close to Mercury's orbit from
data that you're effectively
demonstrating elliptic curve
interpolation yeah
yeah yeah I think like generally it's
it's interesting to think about how you
would impose other priors so like
Einstein had other things to work with
obviously not just Dynamics data
um and I think that is something I'm
very excited about language models for
is you can provide like very flexible
data representations into the model
um
uh yeah so I have a question about like
on a high-level uh why do we expect
scientific principles to be simple and
like that seems to be having some kind
of reductionist uh assumption about
science while there are a lot of complex
systems that might be like not very well
explained by these kind of rigid uh
symbolic Expressions so I don't think
science is simple I think uh I think
when we talk about Simplicity we talk
about it in
terms of like simple in the basis of my
existing ideas
so if you think about like plus like
adding numbers that is a very abstract
idea
like the fact that we consider like
adding two numbers to be simple that's
just because we've learned it and it's
become so familiar to us but it's not
like we have a register for adding
numbers in our brains that like it's uh
these are very abstract Concepts and I
think when we talk about simplicity
you should have like a very clear
objective so interpretation you should
think about
how would this
Insight kind of give me the most inter I
don't know like how would it uh be most
interpretable to me
uh and kind of choose
how you measure complexity in that way
or you could think about like the fpga
example like complexity is the number of
clock Cycles to compute this thing
and so that's like a completely
different objective
um but I like there's definitely not a
universal definition of complexity like
it's kind of like a yeah it's
it's hard to Define it's it's a it's
ultimately like a philosophical black
hole to think about this yeah
so I have a question going back to I
think the mission is bringing up if you
you said that you know you have very
little data with 30 objects for 30 years
if you you know but back then they had
like what 10 objects or something they
could actually track that was uh you
know kind of planetary type things that
um
yeah so if you had that for like 10
years or something your neural net was
still trained we still trained a very
low loss
uh-huh right but it would you're saying
it learn something wrong but you could
still do what you did and you extract
the simple symbolic expression that
comes out of it
you'll presumably still be simple
and fit well yeah but be wrong
uh it'll be really cool to see what that
would have been that would have looked
like yeah I think so too so the so the
way it actually happened was uh so
Kepler fit his his law and then so
Newton's gravity was to kind of explain
that rather than the raw data like here
it's different in that we're fitting
Newton's law of gravity directly to the
raw data
um which is a bit different historically
yeah
so going back the idea of an AI
scientist what was interesting to me is
that if you have this methodology
it would presumably presume simple
looking things yeah that could be wrong
yeah
uh yeah I mean it like it was wrong like
like Newton's law of gravity is wrong
but it's uh it's it's uh
mostly right yeah this would be stuff
that is wrong totally wrong yeah it's a
it's a good approximation and it's uh
yeah
thank you a quick question about this do
you think did you try this on the
Lorenzen Dynamics
like I mean would it learn the law and
subtractor it's a very simple system but
it's extremely chaotic yeah I mean it
depends like a lot of it depends on how
you set up your network and how you
impose specific inductive biases so if
you're learning a dynamical model you
would probably want to do like a neural
differential equation and kind of learn
an update Rule and then fit symbolic
equations to that but if you just like
fed in a Json file of Dynamics to a
language model it would be much harder
to interpret like it's not that
different from a planetary system right
like you have you have positions there
is finally a dynamic I mean it's finally
a physical yeah like if you set up the
induction bias correctly it would be I
think it would be easy to find that law
okay yeah
if I in this first one question I'm
sorry
um that um can I come back to this issue
of how much you need the neural net I
mean if I understand correctly the
answer you gave was oh look maybe you've
got a neural net that's a composition of
two parts FAQ and okay and therefore
I'll be able to do a symbolic expression
for each half yeah
um but it seems like the extent that
that's a win for you you're exploiting
prior human knowledge of the domain
because that's presumably why the human
being designed the net like that unless
you're doing some kind of neural net
structure induction separately
um and I mean it sort of seems like
it also seems like that kind of
composing from Parts is only limitedly
useful because right if you did too much
of that you'd kill your goal right you
know like if the neural net was
something like even like a two-layer
Transformer and I said well let me um
learn a symbolic expression for each
um cell in the mid layer and then
another cell what's computed at the top
layer well something would come out of
the symbolic regression but it'd be so
complex that no one would want to look
at it anymore right
um definitely yeah so yeah um okay so
okay uh so it's it's uh
like why would you not fit directly
um so ultimately
like neural networks maybe uh okay so
for our problems you require like a
million steps like a million gradient
descent steps genetic algorithm to fit
that complexity you have to do a billion
evaluations because genetic algorithms
are much less efficient
um you don't have gradients right
there's there's some approaches that
uses gradients but they're not as good
as genetic algorithms
um so
uh it's much easier to train a neural
network on the raw data and then do like
a student teacher with the genetic
algorithm because then you only have to
fit the input outputs
of say uh the the neural network so it
just mean squared air and it's much more
efficient than having to do
uh this like multi-step
um kind of aggregation in the neural
network so that's one reason yeah the
other reason is the factorization like
training the neural network first will
kind of factorize it into
um sub-expressions
so you do need to have some kind of
knowledge some prior knowledge about how
that structure should work I mean you
could also like learn it as you
suggested maybe so in our example we
impose that the pooling isn't is a sum
but maybe you could have like different
pooling and then kind of sparsify it so
it picks one of them
um but it is it is kind of something you
have to impose I mean like
if you
um
like if you try to do this symbolic
distillation and it just doesn't work
well you've chosen the wrong inductive
bias I mean I I think that's like a good
General
um way to tell if you've chosen the
wrong inductive bias or not
um luckily in a lot of physics problems
we do have
like if we don't know the specific law
we do have good inductive biases because
we know like causality cannot be
violated uh there's different symmetries
that have to be enforced because we know
energy conservation or whatever exists
um so they're like in in science I think
there's a lot of inductive biases that
you can exploit
maybe a little more philosophical but
you open the talk by saying quote I want
to build an AI scientist yeah this
clearly seems like one piece of a bigger
puzzle in that respect and I'm kind of
curious what the rest of the picture
looks like yeah I mean yeah that's a
great question so I think uh I mean it's
more kind of like a call to action like
I wish more people would work on
um
just automating scientific research like
in the Natural Sciences
um
so this is kind of the model Discovery
aspect it's not even the theory
development aspect it's like going from
data to empirical equation but we still
need to kind of have some way of
building up theories that give you that
empirical relation we need to have
experiment design methods
um and I I really don't have a good
handle on how the whole picture would
look but we do ultimately need that
whole Loop
to actually automate um science
so yeah I mean there's a lot of work to
do
yeah
right well it seems like we're about to
come to the end of the questions and it
is three o'clock when coffee is meant to
start again so thanks a lot miles thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
yes